florian et jean baptiste sont étudiants
à belfort il y a un an avec leurs amis
le cas ils se sont lancés dans un
véritable défi imaginer et mettre au
point des montres haut de gamme
un hommage à leur passion et à leurs
racines familiales
on s'est rencontré avec mes deux autres
associés à l'esta donc l'école espère
des technologies des affaires mme et en
s'approchant on s'est vite rendu compte
que tous les trois avions un point
commun on avait tous les trois nos
grands pères qui étaient ici du milieu
horloger
donc on s'était dit on avait tous envie
aussi et ce côté entreprenariale et on
s'est dit bon destin il faut faire
quelque chose dans l'horlogerie et c'est
comme ça qu'est née lutèce une marque de
montres fabriquées entre la
franche-comté et la suisse est ici
chacun a son rôle
l'orient ancien stagiaire chez psa s'est
chargé de l'ergonomie et du design
c'est pas du tout le même univers que
l'automobile en fait on ne s'adapte est
vraiment à la microtechnique que je ne
maîtrisais pas au départ est vraiment
j'ai appris sur sur sur le moment donc
j'ai réalisé j'ai fait la conception sur
les logiciels de ses eaux qui sont les
mêmes que dans l'automobile et la mise
en plan pour la production ensuite il ya
assez de lumière
là je pense qu'on est bien en un tout
petit peu voilà on est très bien je
prends les deux pour l'instant la petite
pme est hébergé dans cette pépinière
d'entreprises voilà alors j'ai reçu les
nouveaux bracelets
bon ça c'est les nouveaux qui viennent
de besançon ici ils travaillent sur tous
les aspects de la marque pour être prêt
à se lancer dans un secteur ultra
concurrentiel ça prend du temps
d'imposer une marque je crois pas qu'on
en soit là aujourd'hui d'imposer la
marque tout de suite sur les trois
premiers mois on est là pour montrer
qu'on a un projet qui plaît un concept
qui plaît et puis ma la suite doit
pouvoir venir
la suite c'est de se faire une place
face aux géants de l'horlogerie en
attendant les étudiants peaufinent leurs
projets dans leur école avec l'aide de
leurs enseignants
bon alors vous emmener tous deux non non
ce site internet montrez moi si je
change par exemple le bracelet je vais
je vais pouvoir la voir évoluer le bras
cet échange en direct mais ça c'est
génial c'est beaucoup mieux que la
première formule c'est bon pour le
territoire j'espère surtout qu'ils même
si demain il faut une entreprise
internationale n'oublierons pas qu'il
sondait dans le territoire de belfort
c'est peut être aussi source de création
d'emplois et il craint surnom plat
autour de nous c'est assez fortement
bénéfique jeu commercial actuellement en
pré commande sur internet les montres
seront livrés à partir de cet été
les trois amis eux travaillent déjà sur
un nouveau prototype celui d'une montre
spécialement dédié aux femmes